et organiser
éducation encore avec ce mouvement de
fièvre qui a saisi aujourd'hui
l'enseignement supérieur la fel la cgt
la cfdt l'unef ont lancé un appel à la
grève pour faire obstacle à une
proposition de loi votée par l'assemblée
nationale la semaine dernière et examiné
demain par le sénat proposition qui
réduit fortement le collège électoral
des présidents d'université ce qui va
disent les protestataires à l'encontre
de la loi d'orientation 2009 168 12
novembre 1968 la loi d'orientation sur
les universités ou loi edgar faure est
votée à la hâte avec soulagement et à
l'unanimité l'accord était totale sur
les défauts du système antérieur cause
des révoltes de mai c'est-à-dire
l'inertie de structures figées depuis
napoléon est soumise un centralisme
étouffant la loi se veut une porte
ouverte à toutes les expériences à la
recherche et au dynamisme doyen et
facultés d'antan sont morts à la place
des universités divisé en unités
d'enseignement et de recherche les yeux
er trois piliers soutiennent la réforme
premier pilier la pluridisciplinarité
littéraires et scientifiques ne devrait
plus être cloisonné deuxième pilier
l'autonomie financière d'abord chaque
université vote et dispose de son budget
autonomie pédagogique ensuite
l'université est maître de ses
structures et de ses programmes
l'autonomie renforcée par le troisième
pilier la participation ou cogestion
chaque 1er est géré par un conseil
composé équitablement de professeurs
titulaires d'assistant d'étudiants de
personnels non-enseignants tous élus et
de personnalités extérieures
même principe au niveau supérieur pour
le conseil d'université mini parlement
et dont le président professeur
titulaire est élu pour cinq ans maximum
et par ces mêmes catégories de personnel
et c'est ce que l'amendement remettent
en cause les directeurs du 1er et les
présidents d'université seront
professeurs de rang magistral élus par
leurs pairs un quart seulement des
conseils justification officielle avoir
des président d'une haute compétence
mais ils sont les réactions on parle de
retour au mandarinat d'enterrement de la
loi de 68 le gouvernement s'est donné
des moyens pour beaucoup mieux contrôler
l'élection des professeurs et maîtres de
conférences les nominations et
maintenant ces gens beaucoup plus
filtrer par les instances ministérielles
seront seuls à élire le président et
ensuite les présidents auront des
pouvoirs accentuée d'où une régression
très sérieuse de la démocratie la plus
élémentaire dans l'université quant aux
étudiants à se saouler plus touchées
même s'il faut toujours partie des
conseils mais la participation aux
élections est peu élevé 13% l'an dernier
à paris l'unef renouveau proche du pc
représentent 60 % des délégués étudiants
et se sentent directement visé c'est la
plus grave mesures prises contre la
démocratie à l'université elle vise à
retirer aux étudiants aux personnels et
à la majorité des enseignants tout
pouvoir dans la désignation des
présidents d'universités et directeurs
du r qui ont pour charge de diriger leur
université je crois que toute forme de
démocratie gène madame le ministre
puisque je pense que ce sont les
résultats de ces élections
universitaires qui sont en train de se
dérouler et qui prouve un nouveau succès
des listes syndicales notamment des
listes de l'unef chez les étudiants qui
font peur à madame le ministre on est
justement elle parle de politisation
excessive
nous nous pensons qu'il est normal que
les étudiants se dote de ddd qu'ils
fassent entendre leurs revendications
leurs problèmes et les défendant les
conseille madame saunier ses hits
ministre des universités dénonce avec
vigueur la politisation 18 présidents
sur 75 serait communiste elle ne cache
guère son hostilité à la loi de 68
estiment que les présidents sont élus
par des coalitions politiques éphémère
cela dit si cet amendement est
définitivement voté des conflits risque
fort de surgir dans le fonctionnement
des conseils entre le président et une
majorité qui ne l'aura pas élu
les sony s'était qui n'a pas souhaité se
prononcer chez nous avant son
intervention demain au sénat